Hi.
My name is Daniel Olshansky.
And today I'll be showing you
how to do an animation to
extend cells in the ListView.
So if you have a ListView with
certain data and you want to
show extra content associated
with every single cell,
instead of taking the user to
a new page, you can simply
click on a cell, expand it,
show the extra content and
collapse it.
A few of the things about this
animation is that as a cell
expands, it moves around all
the items around it to make
room for the new
extra content.
And furthermore, this
new size persists.
So if you were to expand a cell,
then scroll away from
it, and then come back to it,
the new size will persist on
the expanded cell until it is
collapsed manually by the user
by clicking on the cell again.
A couple of the tricks and the
problems they came across
while implementing this
animation is the fact that
when you animate a cell-- when
you change the layout of a
cell, what's going to happen
is that some of the other
cells around it are going
to disappear.
They're going to be
moved outside the
bounds of the ListView.
And when this happens, you no
longer have a reference to
those views.
So even though you still need
to animate them to achieve
that animation effect.
That's problem number one.
The second problem when working
with this is that when
you change the layout of a
certain view in the ListView,
the Container, what's going to
happen is that the ListView
will try to rearrange the
cells as it wants to
make room for it.
But if you want to choose some
sort of custom expansion, such
that when you expand the cell
all the content should be
visible, or as much of it as
can be visible to the user,
should be visible once.
You're going to want to
rearrange the cells in a way
that's most optimal for
your application.
And in this case, you need to
tell the ListView exactly how
to place them on the screen.
So going straight
into the demo.
Here we have a ListView of
chameleons, rocks, and flowers.
And say I click on a cell,
see how it expands,
displays a new text.
And then you can click
again to close it.
This works for every
single cell.
It works for extra content
of different sizes.
You can also see that as a cell
expands and collapses,
the actual content, the
text, actually fades
in and fades out.
And this is not only
restricted to text.
This will also work with
other types of layouts.
Another interesting thing about
this is that, say the
cell is at the edge and
you want to expand it.
You can see that it'll animate
it to make room for it.
So if we were to animate, to
bring this flower down, and we
click here, it'll actually
animate upwards instead of
animating downwards.
And then when I click on it,
it makes room for all the
other cells and then animates
them back in.
So jumping straight to the code,
here in Custom ListView,
which extends the ListView
which can expand
and collapse cells.
First we initiate an item like
click listener, so that when
you click and click again, you
can expand or collapse it,
respectively.
And then scrolling down
furthermore, this is the Get
Top and Bottom Translations
method.
So what this does, this can be
customized by you depending
what kind of user experience
you'd like.
But in this specific case, what
I did is always try to
maximize the amount of content
that displayed to the user.
And all it is is really just
a little bit of math, and a
little bit of arithmetic,
using the bounds of the
ListView, using how much, what
the current offset is, and
using what the size of the
current visible part of the
ListView as well.
So this will return a
bottom and a top.
And all this will say is how
much the bottom and the top
bounds of the expanding or the
collapsing cell should be
modified by.
And you can use these as a
reference to animate all the
cells around the cells being
expanded or collapsed.
Scrolling down furthermore.
We reach the expanding method,
which takes in the view that's
being expanded.
And before we actually expand
anything, there's a few things
we need to do.
We need to store what the old
bounds of the cell that's
about to be expanded is.
And we also need to store the
top and bottom bounds of all
the cells that are
around the cell
that's going to be expanded.
After that, we get a reference
of the expanding layout.
So even though it's not
visible at first, the
expanding layout is present
in every single cell.
Except its visibility
is set to gone.
So it's not being rendered.
It's not affecting the
layout at all.
But by sending it to visible, we
now tell it that we want--
by sending it to visible and
have its layout set to wrap
content, what we're actually
going to be doing is invoking
a request layout call without
having that be here
explicitly.
Because we know that now
something that was gone has
become visible.
And we need to render it.
And like I've mentioned in a
few of my other animations,
what we're going to want to do
is add an OnPreDraw Listener.
So by invoking said visible,
we're going to change the
layout of this cell along with
the bounds and the layout of
the cells around it.
And On Layout and On Measurable
get called.
The final values for all the
cells will be computed, but
they will not yet be drawn
on the screen.
So this is the best place
to run animation.
Except the thing about this
animation right here that's
going to be a little different
is that we're going to have
two passes in OnPreDraw
instead of just one.
During the first PreDraw pass,
what we want to do is we want
to offset the content in the
ListView in such a way such
that after we invoke our layout
once again, all the
cells that we want rendered on
the screen will be visible and
will be accessible
to the user.
So if we were not to have this
first pass, the ListView would
arrange all the cells in a way
most convenient for this
ListView to display
the content.
But seeing how we're animating
the top and bottom bounds in a
very custom manner, we need to
specify exactly which cells we
want to have visible.
The way this is done is through
a little bit of math,
determining how much we
need to offset it by.
But the key method I'm
using here is set
selection from top.
So after determining which cell
is going to be at the
very top after my custom changes
for the top and bottom
bounds are run, I know what the
first visible position is
going to be afterwards.
And I also know what
its offset is going
to be from the top.
So doing some math, and then
calling said selection from
top, I set the offset that I
want for the ListView, and
then I call request layout.
So what this is going to do is
render all the cells that I
need to be rendered on the
screen, after having the
ListView be offset by
how much I need.
I'm also going to be returning
false from OnPreDraw.
Because all I'm doing here is
offsetting the content.
But I don't want the current
state of the
M View to be redrawn.
Because if I were to redraw in
two different states, it would
be a very janky and not
a very pleasant
animation for the user.
So returning false, but still
not having removed the PreDraw
Listener, what's going to happen
is it's going to come
back to OnPreDraw after the
new values have been
recomputed.
At which point we
will no longer
need the PreDraw Listener.
Then we go down.
We can retrieve the values from
before for the top and
bottom bound changes.
And then we can get straight
into calculating all the
animations that we need.
So before the animation took
place, we stored the top and
bottom bounds for all
the cells that
were previously visible.
And so if it was visible before
the animation and the
cell is still visible after the
animation, we're going to
go into this else case.
And all we need to do is animate
the bounds from the
before state to the after
state, which is very
straightforward.
This is what happens
when the Parent of
the view is not known.
So this means it was visible
before the layout change and
it's also present after
the layout change.
But say the cell expanded so
much that the cell will no
longer be visible after
the layout change.
We're going to see that our
View's parent is null.
So it's no longer contained
in the ListView.
But up here, when I created
my hash map, I said
setHasTransientState to true.
So what that did is even though
it's no longer part of
the ListView, this view is
not going to be recycled.
And as long as I store the
reference to this ListView
myself, I can still make use
of it after the layout has
taken place as long as I
have a reference to it.
So scrolling down here, all
I'm going to do is add the
exact same animation as I do
for cells that are still
visible after the layout.
Except I'm also going to add
it to this array of mine
called mViewsToDraw, which is
going to tell me that this is
a view that needs to be animated
off the screen, just
for animation purposes.
But it doesn't actually need
to be rendered for the
purposes of the ListView use.
So scrolling down furthermore,
I add animation to actually
expand the bounds of the
cell being expanded.
And then I also fade in the
expanding layout text.
So this does not necessarily
have to be text, but the
layout itself is faded in by
animating its alpha value from
zero to one.
Then during the animation
itself, I wanted to see all my
ListView to prevent some weird
behavior if the user were to
scroll during that time.
And once my animation completes,
one thing that I
really have to do is make sure
to set the transient state to
false for any views that
previously had it to true, so
that these views don't get
stored but can actually be
recycled and make lists you're
scrolling more efficient
afterwards.
So that was expand view.
Now in dispatchDraw, what's
going to happen is the only
things that I would want to draw
on to the screen that are
not on the screen right now
are views that were on the
ListView, but are no longer on
the ListView afterwards.
I only need a reference to these
during the animation.
Because once the animation
completes, the user should not
be able to track them anymore.
And so since I have a reference
to the view itself,
all I need to do is transfer the
canvas appropriately, just
its top value.
Because the cell takes up the
whole width, I just need to
modify where it's located
vertically on the screen.
I draw the view onto
the canvas.
And then I translate it back
so that the next cell to be
drawn will be drawn in the
correct location as well.
Scrolling down furthermore
into Collapse View.
It's going to be very similar
in most ways.
So before the cells collapse,
I want to store the top and
bottom bounds of all the cells
prior to the collapse.
I want to set Translate to True
so nothing gets recycled
during the collapsing
animation.
And then the only really
important thing to note here
is that I'm not changing the
expanding layout visibility
from visible to gone.
What I'm actually doing is
setting the height of the
layout to a custom height that
I pre-computed before, which
is what its default height
is when it's
in a collapsed state.
And the reason I can't set the
visibility to gone and just
work with the layout change from
there is because I want
to get that fading effect as the
cell is collapsing on the
expanding layout.
And that fading effect cannot
be achieved if the expanding
layout visibility is
gone or invisible.
By setting the height to a
custom value, I can then
invoke a layout and
add an OnPreDraw
Listener like we did before.
Very similar to the expand view
method, I'm going to have
two passes.
The first pass is going to
offset the ListView in such a
way to account for the
custom collapse that
I'm going to achieve.
And once again I'm going to call
set selection from top,
request a layout, and make sure
to return false so the
TransientState of the ListView
does not get
drawn onto the screen.
And then since the PreDraw
Listener has not yet been
removed, I'm going to request
that it has been called again.
It'll come back here for its
second pass, where I will
firstly loop through
all the visible
children in the ListView.
If I find that I do have access
to the old bounds of
that view in the ListView, that
means that this view was
present in the ListView before
and after the collapse.
At which point, all I need to
do is update its bounds and
then later animate them.
But if I find that I don't have
access to the old bounds
of the cell, that means that
this cell became visible only
after the collapse
of the view.
So the collapse of the view
actually made room for new
cells to appear.
But since I don't know what
their old bounds were, I don't
have a reference point from
where I want to animate them.
And so I just used the top and
bottom translation values to
account for that.
Scrolling down here, I loop
through all these same views
and add the animations to
actually animate them from
these old bounds to
their new bounds.
I also want to animate
the collapse of
the collapsing cell.
And I want to animate the
expanding layout from a value
of one to a value of zero,
so it disappears.
Then I play all of these
together in an animator set.
And then once it's actually
done, what I do is set the
expanding layout visibility
to gone.
So it doesn't get rendered on
the screen at all anymore, nor
is it visible.
And I also update my layout
parameters to wrap content.
Because when it's gone, I want
to just wrap the content,
which means that none
of the expanding
layout should be wrapped.
And then here, get animation.
This is actually how I animate
the top and bottom bounds.
And since top and bottom have
associated setters in Views,
called set top and set bottom,
these values can be animated
as I would like for
them to be.
And then I just return
Object Animator, and
it does what I need.
The one other thing that I
wanted to mention in this
animation is how I actually
managed to achieve the
collapse of the expanding layout
while fading it out.
So what's going to happen is
when I set the height of the
layout to be a collapsed state,
the ListView will not
want to render the expanding
layout because it's not
visible on the screen.
So what I do here is overwrite
OnMeasure, OnSize, and
onSizeChanged.
And what I'm telling it to do
is that when it doesn't want
to display the expanding layout
content, but if it
previously was in expanding
layout state, by overriding
OnMeasure and returning the
bigger height as opposed to
the smaller height, will
keep it visible.
And that lets me animate
its alpha value.
And once it's completely
collapsed, that's when I set
it to gone, because I
don't have anything
else to do with it.
So that's how you
can expand and
collapse cells in ListView.
Thanks for watching.